enquête maurice papon va se retrouver
jeudi le nouveau devant un tribunal mais
cette fois ci c'est lui qui porte
plainte il poursuit en diffamation
l'historien jean luc einaudi pour ses
propos dans le monde sur la répression
de la manifestation algérienne du 17
octobre 61 en quête de nos confrères de
france 3 2 france 3 et malgré gagner
bruno l'hiver tout ce soir là lorsqu'il
sort du métro wazemmes saada les mains
sur la tête pour se protéger des coups
de matraque
comme des milliers d'autres algériens
sur andres du fln le mouvement
indépendantiste
il est venu manifester pacifiquement à
paris contre le couvre feu les forces de
l'ordre les attendent à faire sur nous
un carnage il tapait par tous les moyens
ce qu'ils avaient dans sous les mains on
peux pas vous dire cesser des barres de
fer ou les maths ragots des coups de
crosse bilan officiel de la répression
policière trois morts 200 d'après le fln
une centaine selon cet ancien
responsable syndical de la police les
agents d'un si tu me dis que légales
étaient des garçons s'inviter à notre
c'est notre organisation
or tous deux ont dit que jean cet
homme-là ils ont reçu plus d'une
centaine de cadavres et que pour évacuer
on rejetait souvent les cadres à la
scène les raisons de ce déchaînement des
forces de l'ordre les attentats du fln
contre les policiers dans les mois
précédents mais aussi ce 17 octobre
d'étranges rumeurs sur les ondes de la
police il a été dit que des collègues
auraient été tirés auraient été abattus
par part des nord africains s'étaient
entièrement fond mais pour certains le
responsable de ce drame se serait
maurice papon alors préfet de police de
paris bat prend à ussel parole
dramatique pour un coup reçu
nous aurons 10 mais dans le climat qui
avait à ce mandat et formation ça a été
interprété l'inévitable le mans pourra
tuer on en tueur à 10 cet ancien
collaborateur de maurice papon est
formel le fln porterait la
responsabilité des violences
on pouvait pas tolérer qu'ils aillent
manifester sous les fenêtres du général
de gaulle nous l'accorderez quand même
c'était pas pensable
c'était pas penser à paul et et corey
pensée l'armée française en algérie
alors quand alors qu'on les sait tout
faire ici c'était pas possible
un débat sur lequel la justice va se
pencher à partir de demain les juges
devront dire si l'historien jean luc
einaudi à diffamer maurice papon en
affirmant publiquement que l'ancien
préfet était responsable de la mort de
plusieurs centaines d'algériens police